thanks for coming to the session tour
and building for enterprise IOT
my name is internal Chakraborty and I'm
one of the product guy at Google cloud
platform focusing on IOT and in this
session what we're going to cover is
we're going to cover some of the key
products and services which Google has
has has for building IOT solution some
of the key challenges that we've seen
and we've heard from developers and
partners and how Google thinks about
addressing those challenges and at the
end we'll have a short demo so so let's
get started there you go
so imagine never have never been stuck
looking for a parking right imagine if
every parking lot every parking space
has a sensor embedded in the space which
can determine whether that space is
occupied or not and it sends the data to
cloud so that every so that as you are
driving looking for parking in city like
Amsterdam or any other city you know
exactly where the parking lot what what
space is open and your car goes and
parks there I imagine if you know in
u.s. it is believed that there are
around 800 million parking spaces
imagine if all those spaces have sensors
embedded imagine the amount of data that
we generated in order for us to figure
out which of the space is available and
sent the data down to you the
applications such as Google Maps let's
fix some couple some more examples at
Google we've used deep learning machine
learning to reduce the amount of energy
needed for cooling data centers were
almost 40% so imagine if you can
optimize the power consumption in all
the commercial buildings by applying the
same principle right so where you you
collect real-time data from your HVAC
from your coolers from ambient
temperatures humidity lights coolers and
all the data and and you build machine
learning models using historical data
over time and then you apply those
predictions based on these models to to
optimize for your car consumption
and commercial building so these is this
such applications like this could be
really revolutionary and we seeing some
patterns in the industry on some of the
customers building such and such
applications as well utility is another
example utility providers have been
installing smart meters over the last
couple of years and now by collect
connecting the smart meters to cloud
they can get a real-time view of power
consumption in a city and also break it
down by neighborhoods within a city as
well now then now they can compare the
real-time demand with forecast and they
can balance the power distribution
real-time as well so these are some of
the revolutionary applications we see
when you use the sensor data and our
cloud platform to really build
compelling enterprise application very
soon cities will have millions of smart
meters sending energy data energy
reading real-time so we believe that IOT
is at an inflection point where we
expect significant growth over the next
couple of years in fact if you think
about if you look at the projection
while phones mobile phones growth has
been much bigger than personal computers
a much higher growth wave is expected
for IOT depending on the the analyst
report you read it is expected estimated
that around twenty to thirty billion
devices will be connected to Internet by
2020 while each of this device might
send a few hundreds of bytes every few
seconds or minutes or an hour cumulative
that's a massive amount of data which
will be generated by this billions of
devices connected to internet so this
creates a couple of challenges right one
is as you think about building IT
solution that one of the key challenges
security how do you make sure that all
these devices that are connected are
secured they are not compromised and
also the data which being general which
is being generated
by these devices are securely stored on
on cloud or on on-prem second is scale
right so when you have millions or even
billions of devices connecting to the
cloud how do you ensure that we can
build application that can ingest this
massive influx of data and store it
cost-effectively and how do you make
sure that your when you have this
millions of devices that all these
devices have the right form wave version
they have the right security patches as
well so you're not worried about
fragmentation in your fleet of deployed
devices and it finally when you have
data what do you do with the data what
do you do with the massive data how do
you get actionable insights so that it
can really use it use it for to optimize
your business process or to glean
specific insights which will help in
your business so we've been working hard
over the last couple of years to really
make it easier for developers to build
IOT solution on Google cloud and so
which are there is secure scalable as
well as you can get actionable insight
as well I think you all know that Google
has around seven products consumer
products there is more than one there
are more than 1 billion users active
active users they're edging engaging
with these products so as part of a
mission to organize the world's
information we've been working with
we've been working with and dealing with
massive scale of data big data for over
a decade now and in the process of
handling the scale of data we've also
built the one of the world's best
compute infrastructure across hardware
software and networking and operations
we've built infrastructure such that for
developers it's just one computer it's
not a collection of computers and they
just you know developers you just write
code and write applications and we take
care of the running them across
different data centers or scaling them
across different infrastructure as well
in addition to a data data center
infrastructure we've also been working
hard in building up our data management
technical stack as well right so you've
heard about pop sub Vickery BigTable
everything that Google has built which
we use internally for our own
development and are used by internal
developers are in the process of being
externalized so recently a word about
tensorflow
which we are also packages as cloud ml
spanner is another example so we believe
that you know we we know we believe that
we have the industry-leading
services when it comes to data analytics
and machine learning and many of our
developers partners and enterprise
customers have been leveraging these
cloud platform services to build
enterprise applications well when it
comes to IOT the same developers and
partners have have asked as before that
it's great that you have the services
but how do we connect our devices to
Google cloud and how do we manage those
devices to Google cloud so we can start
benefiting to start to benefit from the
machine learning and data analytic
services that you have so last month
we're pretty excited that we announced a
product called priority core it's a new
service on Google cloud platform with
the singular goal of making it really
easy for developers to build Enterprise
IT applications
what is clarity core it's a fully
managed service to securely connect and
manage your devices on Google cloud
platform so what we've done is first we
have we have added support for the
industry standard protocol MQTT now we
understand where as we talk to partners
and developers we realize that many of
these devices existing devices which
already applied or even new devices they
use mqtt for machine to machine and even
machine to cloud messaging so with
quadratic or you can securely connect
your device
using TLS and then use impunity
messaging protocol for sending telemetry
to Google cloud the second feature of
the second key thing of Clara dhikr is
we scale internally whether you're
connecting one device or you scale up to
millions of device you don't have to
worry about provisioning a new node or a
new instance or a new infrastructure we
scale internally and we can handle
millions or even billions of devices as
you scale up or scale down and we also
have with we tightly integrated this
with pub/sub which allows you to get a
central view of your globally dispersed
devices I'm going to talk a little bit
more about how that works in a few
minutes we've also added functionality
some key functionalities for device
management so you can you can
individually configure your device to
make sure that each device is
authenticated at its own separately
right so we we have support for per
device asymmetric keys based
authentication using JSON web token and
this ensures that this in fact limits
the surface area of attack so even if a
public key or private key is compromised
it will only affect that particular
device not the rest of your fleet so
we've added per device authentication as
part of a device management capability
with clarity core with quadratic or you
can also send configuration and updates
to your devices from the cloud as well
you can control your devices from Google
cloud and you can even control access to
two users to a set of devices or a group
of devices using cloud I am axis can be
granted at a project level on Google
cloud or at a registry level if you have
if you have assigned in a cloud I am at
a project level then all the registries
by default will inherit that those roles
but you can also refine it at individual
raise to level as well and finally we
have rich set of api's for you to build
your compelling enterprise application
on top of clarity core
so we have announced we've announced
this last month as a private beta and
we're getting interesting good feedback
from our partners and developers have we
planned to make it available more
broadly in a next couple of months so I
want to spend a little bit of time on on
the resource model for for a device
management capability on clarity core so
let's say if you are a device
manufacturer and you have ten different
categories of devices you you will go to
chloride pluggable cloud and you have a
project under project you can create ten
different registries each for your each
of your device category and registry
essentially is a collection of devices
right so you can create you know for
each category one registry and it under
each rate so you can register as many
devices as you want you can have
millions of devices under each registry
and a device in a when your registry
device is essentially a logical
representation of your physical device
so we store the credential for the
device so as when you add a device or
any register device to your registry you
have to add the public key which will be
used for authentication we also we also
store the configuration and eventually
we'll add States as well so it's an
exact representation of your physical
device on the cloud side so you can have
multiple registries per project and each
registry can you can register as many
devices as you want so this really gives
you the ability to manage a massive
scale of device devices and your and you
can group them based on your specific
use case you can assign
like as I mentioned a certain access
control at a registry level so for
example you can say that you know I you
can create a clora I'm provision quraíam
role called provisioner at a registry so
all the users which belong to that role
will only be able to add or edit device
but not remove or
new registry so you have this brand
allure level of access control that you
can provide at register level and as we
were building this product table and
releasing this product we realized and
we understand that both developers and
enterprise partners would want to first
you know build some quick prototype to
wet their feet before they do full-scale
development so we have a simple UI as
well as part of clarity core for
management and monitoring of devices so
what you see here is if you go to cloud
if you go to the cool cloud console they
will want the drop down menu there will
be a section for IOT core if it's select
click on IOT core you would see all the
registries that has been already added
by you previously you can also create a
new registry and I'll show you the demo
later down and in mind in my session so
the top one shows a list of all the
registries which has been added you know
you you can also see you can assign an
ID to it you can select a region where
you want all the devices raised to that
device to have its storage metadata and
it shows the different protocols that
registry devices support one interesting
thing about my core and registry is we
have what we're done is for you can you
can assign a pub subtopic to a registry
what that means is all the data which
all the device data from in which are
which belongs to that registry will be
published to that pop subtopic so while
each individual device will be sending
publishing its data on a particular
topic but we'll get aggregated and
published at a pop subtopic so you can
get a real global view of all your
devices by consuming data from pop
subtopic as well and when you select on
the registry on UI you can see you can
get a list of devices those are that are
registered in that in that registry and
you can see some simple status such as
enable/disable when was the last message
received by that particular device so
you can do some simple monitoring as
well and if you go drill down even more
you can select on popular device and get
some additional information about
that those divided that particular
device as well so it's a simple way for
you to get started where you can quick
do some some create some registry add
some devices and start playing with the
product and really start connecting the
data to build a simple application as we
launch article we've also announced
partnership agreement with some of our
with our leading device manufacturers
and software vendors as well so such as
Intel microchip nxp sierra wireless harm
all these soft caldas hardware partners
have agreed to support cloud IT core and
we're working very closely with these
partners to to make it really easy for
developers to have this partner devices
seamlessly connected to our article so
imagine if the way to work is if you
purchase a device from NXP it will have
a very simple instruction where you can
to show you how to connect that device
to clout attic or in fact moving forward
will we're working hard with these
partners so that when you buy a device
it just connect when you have an input
sup it'll just automatically connect to
already code and in fact thanks to some
of our partners such as mongoose you can
you can connect any microcontroller it's
you know this is a tiny MCU device built
by expressive it's a esp8266 you can use
you can have this tiny device connect
directly connect to cloud IOT core as
well so you can set up a TLS connection
using the software made by mongoose OS
and and their sample code which shows
you how you can use how you can connect
these devices directly to the cloud
article they can they have the ability
to generate public key so you can
authenticate each of this device
individually and in a secure way so
really excited about this and so we're
working we'll continue to work hard with
with bunch of our a lot of our new
partners as well so you'll hear a lot
more about our partner ecosystem going
forward and you can visit i would really
encourage you guys to visit a site
cloud.google.com / io t / partners so
see the list of device
software partners who have with whom we
have agreement for clerical and we're
working with a lot more of them so we'll
see you hear a lot more down the road so
I talked about securely connecting your
device and and some aspects of how you
can manage these devices on cloud but
once you have connected the device how
do you ingest the massive amount of data
from your millions of billions of
devices and pub/sub is is great for that
what pops of allows you to do is couple
of key things one is it is a global
service so you may have devices
dispersed across the globe but with
pub/sub you can get a central view of
all the data been published across all
these devices what pub/sub also has is
it has durable persistent message so you
know it promises that the message from a
device is stored until until
acknowledgment or return message is sent
back to the device so this is this makes
a lot of sense when you have use case
where you don't want to particularly for
medical devices where you don't want to
lose any data pops-up is a great way to
serve route the data downwards and pops
of also allows helps us to decouple your
upstream devices from a downstream
application so with this because a pop
sub you can continue to iterate on your
application which is consuming the data
without without needing to change or
update your upstream devices and you can
for example have cloud function consume
subscribe to a topic from pub sub which
you can use to build some simple rules
you can use cloud dataflow for some
complex complex event processing or even
you can use the existing ETL pipeline
you consume the data which has been
generated by all these devices connected
to erratic or through pops up so with
clarity color and pop sub and the
conjunction of this you can securely
connect to devices but also in just
massive amount of data without worrying
about provisioning or creating new
infrastructure
so once you've connected and ingested
next step is what do you do with the
data
so I've here I've listed some key
examples of the different services
existing cloud services which you can
use for storage and analysis and so yeah
bigquery is is great for calibrating the
understanding of the data right so you
can have hundreds of billions of rows of
data and you can drill them some quick
way to really understand what's what are
the typical trends you're seeing on the
data you can even use data flow to clean
up the data and build some simple models
you can create some simple regression
models using data flow and then further
down you can then use machine learning
cloud ml to creates to train some tensor
flow model using the data which you have
generated and stored on Vickery or even
BigTable so we have all the services to
name a few bigquery data flow Big Data
lab and the cloud ml for once you've
gathered the data to glean insights and
build models train models on all those
data as well so here is a view of how we
see the sort of the entire IOT platform
as you think about building IOT solution
on Google Cloud so you have clarity core
which sits between the devices and
Google Cloud for you to securely connect
and manage your data the data gets
published it pops up and from there you
can write some simple rules using cloud
function for example you can say every
time the median temperature or the
temperature goes about 90 degrees I want
to turn on the fan so you can write some
simple rules using cloud function and
you can send command back to you to your
devices using clarity code or you can
use data flow for doing some complex
event processing as well and once you
have done that once you have cleaned up
the data based on using dataflow jobs
you can store it in beaker your big
table for further analysis and report
generation then you know you can use
cloud ml like as I mentioned to build
some machine learning models train
models and then
use prediction cloud ml predictions to
act on the data and send some relevant
commands back to the to their devices as
well so overall we have on the cloud
side I talked about how you can you can
you can connect your devices to Google
Cloud ingest them at scale without
worrying about whether it's a few device
and millions of our millions of devices
without needing to provision any
infrastructure and you can use our
existing services such as cloud ml and
bigquery and data lab for data analysis
and storage I want to spend some time on
how we can how we can take care of
security scale and insights at the edge
itself and we have Android things for
which is a fully managed operating
system for devices and edge gateways so
Android things essentially is Android
operating system that is optimized to
run on IOT devices now what does it mean
so what we've done is we've taken the
Android stock Android and we've removed
the components which doesn't is not
relevant to IOT for example we've
removed all the you know notification
the system UI piece user applications
and and then added some specific IOT
components such as peripheral i/o and a
device driver support so you can connect
additional component to your devices and
then run Android things on them as well
and and some of the key things which
Android things which you get with
Android things is number one if you want
to build scale right if you want to
build some quick prototype for all the
Android developers out there you can you
can you can you can use a familiar
Android ecosystem such as the Android
SDK the Android studio to build those
applications compiling the apk and run
it on android things you can even try
even if you can even use an existing apk
that you're built for Android mobile
phone and poured it into Android things
as well so this this
really makes it a developer to really
have build quick prototypes on the
device by using the familiar Android
ecosystem and we already have more than
two billion monthly active phones and
tablets which is running Android and now
we're extending it to IOT as well second
is with Android things we also we want
to we have used Android things for
security on the device as well so the
great thing of all Android things is
since its leverages the key component of
security for Android right so it has a
secure boot the applications are signed
and good Google manages the firmware
version of Android things so we will
make sure that all the Android things
devices has the latest firmware has the
right security patches so that you know
none of them can be compromised of
course in cases where enterprise
customer or developers want more control
in terms of when that patch should be
deployed that is available as well and
Android things I'll talk more about
designer things also work seamlessly
with karate core and we are working
harder to make this integration much
more simpler so that was on the software
side of Android things on the hardware
layer we with we're working hard to
remove the complexity of building a
device so we work we're working with
silicon partners to certify their F some
essentially you know system on module so
some will come with your CPU memory
storage and connectivity and and all the
components were to run our Android
things are already built in so you can
start using the certified devices and to
add it to your baseboard and add
necessary components as you feel and
since the song is already certified you
don't have to go through the
certification process separately for for
enterprise customers we have we already
have partners such as NXP Intel Qualcomm
who have we're already building
certified psalm which runs Android
things so you can just take this
opponent and start testing and/or things
for for your specific use case and
finally the last layer for Android
things is really the services right so
we we have we want to make sure that
with Android things you can leverage the
existing Google services as well such as
location services you know a system
service chromecast cast service as well
as our new services such as tensorflow
so great thing about end of Android is
number one it's it's seamlessly work
with clarity so if you have if you have
Android things device it's very easy for
you to connect those device to clarity
and start leveraging the cloud platform
for it and secondly it can Android
things can run can use tensorflow you
can use tensorflow on android things to
run machine learning model locally on
the device right so this is this works
the the Yusuke in in the use case where
latency matters or you don't want to
send every information to the cloud you
can run your tensorflow model locally at
the edge and get the same level of
insights as you would do with with cloud
and i'll talk more about how some give
some specific example so let's take in
this specific example let's say you have
you want to you want to check the
quality control of your product you have
your making a pizza and you want to make
sure that every piece that's been made
in assembly line is meeting your quality
bar right there's there's no template so
so you can use machine learning to look
at the shape of the pizza that comes up
the color the some of the you know the
the texture the temperature and all of
that and really figure out which one is
is meeting a quality bar so in this case
what we do is you'll have a camera where
which is capturing the pictures of the
pizza as it's being manufactured and you
would have you have trained a model on
cloud which automatically can detect
whether a pizza is meeting your bar or
not
and then you can push that trained the
tensorflow model into the into the
camera which is running Android things
so as the camera is capturing the
picture of each of those pizza it is
locally running the trained model to see
if it is really a meets your quality bar
or should it be remade or shouldn't be
rejected and then over time you can send
part of the feed to to cloud throw
through Google Clara attic or so that
you can constantly retrain and update
the model and then download the model
back into the into the local device for
local local processing so these kind of
example with Android things and with
clarity as you can see you you not only
get the the benefit of the massive
infrastructure and on cloud for training
purposes for training your model but you
can also wear it makes sense you can run
some of the processing locally as well
and with Android things you can also
have you can also run some you can build
apk applications where you can do some
course some filtration or some edge
processing on the device and send the
rest of the data to the cloud for
further analysis so wait when you think
about IOT Android things connecting to
IOT there are a couple of steps which
which needs to happen so in this case
when you first go to you create a cloud
project you'd you would have to enable
the cloud IT API and Android things has
has it as a key store which where the
private key is protected and stored
which is so you cannot tamper with it
but you can extract the public key from
the Android things key store and then
you register you take that public key
and you register that device with that
public key with chlorotic or you can any
are for registration you can use cloud
you can use CLI so command-line tools
which we have or even you can use here
they some of the UI as well and once
you've register the device
and it's it's really a third step is
ready to configure your apk to send MQTT
messages to cloud radical and we have a
sample which is already posted on github
you can look it up on get up there comm
/ Android things of really encourage you
guys to look search for it and there's a
simple application sample code which you
can use to to build an a to build an apk
for handle things device which will
connect to clarity core and start
sending data base from your device to
cloud and you can even look at some of
the tensorflow pieces as well so with
with Android things on the edge and with
cloud IT core on the on the cloud side
for secure connection and device
management you can really build start
thinking about building really
compelling application for for
enterprise specific use cases so let me
cue spend some time on some quick demos
so if we switch to the to the computer
great so this is our cloud Google cloud
platform console and if you if you go to
the menu bar you there's a link there
will be a section called IOT core if
it's select on that what happens is you
would see a list of a list of all the
red registries that has already been
added and created before so if you want
to start a new register you go to
chlorotic cloud console you just click
that let me expand it so you can see it
let's say I create a new registry say
Amsterdam session you can select a
region where you want the the registry
all the device metadata for the raid
arrays to for the registry to be stored
you have a select a pop subtopic where
all the different data from all the
devices registered to this registry will
be eventually published so for now I'll
just select one and and then you create
once you do that that device that you
have you have created new registry call
amsterdam session and then after that
you can
had a device as well so every every
physical device which you want to
connect to clarity core you have to here
to register the device into a registry
and then once the device connects they
will use that information which you have
passed to authenticate the device so
when you add a device you can create you
can give any device ID name here by
default it will be enable unless you
want to disable it and for as I've
mentioned for authentication we use part
device private public key pair and we
support two crypto algorithms so we
support RSA as well as ECC so you can
you can choose which crypto algorithm
you want to use and assuming you have
the private key either you can generate
separately or you have it stored you can
extract the public key and add it here
and then just add race to the device you
can register up to three public keys per
device you can also specify an expiry by
default public we won't expire the
public key but if you put a expire then
we will not use a public key for for
authentication so let me show you if I
go to so since I've added a session if I
go to a new register which I have
created before called group register
what I see is there are all these
devices which have registered before and
they're all in disabled State and so
what I've done is you think about the
use case where if you have a large
amount of devices which you want to
connect to cloud so when you register
the device by default you would register
them as disabled and when you know that
the devices has been installed and has
been provisioned then you can enable it
on the cloud side so they can start
connecting to clarity core and start
sending the data so by default all of
them are disabled here and the device ID
here by the way it's just a MAC address
we have used here so as I mentioned you
know we have a rich set of API switch
you can use for registering your devices
you can use
you can use the UI but you can also have
the api's so I have a mobile app here
and all it does right now what it does
is it connects to quadratic or the REST
API on cloud IT core and what I'll do is
I will say I've have looked at the
devices they're ready to go so I want to
enable all these devices so they can
start connecting and start sending data
so I've app here which connects to
quadratical using the REST API and I'll
just say enable devices and you would
see that the devices starts to get
enabled and as it's enabled as the
device starts to connect we can actually
go go to each of the device and see when
was the last time we saw a message so
this is a simple way of battery stirring
your devices and then when you're ready
to do for the devices to connect you can
enable those devices as well now the
other thing I want to show you is we
have we have what we have done is we
have taken a number of a large number of
Raspberry Pi devices which has a
humidity sensor a temperature sensor a
luminosity Center sensor and pressure
and motion sensor as well and we have
deployed it across our Google office in
Mountain View in San Francisco and in
some of the other offices as well and
what we're doing with those is we're
collecting data on a regular basis all
these devices are sending data per
second or sometimes a couple of times a
second and we have created a dashboard
so this registry weather station has a
list of all the devices which are
registered and if I if I select let's
say the top device here it will show you
that the device has we've been lost it's
recently published at data at 2:38 and
there was an error you know sometimes
they when they're Earths we can see that
as well you can you see the public key
here you can also add an additional
public key one other thing which so you
can you can drill down to each device
and see the status when was the last
message sent so you know whether the
device is actually functioning or not
but if you want to actually see the data
you can you can pull the data from pops
top subtopic the other interesting thing
about the device is when you go to the
this section you would see you can
quickly sort of highball and see alright
now this device has center divider data
to that yet but the second device hasn't
sent any data since May 16th if
something is off there so you can sort
of you know drill down and look at the
logs or sort of start investigating and
debugging it as well we also have on the
UI the ability for you to send a
configuration update as well so let me
take a quick look here and we have a
demo we have created there are a couple
of devices which are registered here so
I can just go to cell say this is this
is a relay device which is sitting in in
Mountain View now but what I can do is I
can look at the history of all the
configuration update updates which were
sent from the cloud to the device right
so this this relay is all it what it
does is it if you send a message to it
saying you know fan on : true or false
he'll turn on or off based on what
message you send it to them to the relay
so you can see the different work all
the messages which was sent last month
you click on it you can actually see
what was sent to the device so it's a
very simple JSON object which says fan
on equal to false and or true and that
way what you can do here from UI is if
you want to send a message to the device
you can select just say in text and you
say fan on I can change it to true and
send it'll send it and it'll
automatically update it here listed here
as well and when we get an
acknowledgement back from the device you
would see it in the device details and
so right here when we get so this is
still waiting for an acknowledgement
because the devices is in mantra and
it's not up but you will get see the
last time when the device sent an
acknowledgment back based on the
configuration of the
to ascend so it's a simple UI tool for
you to create a quick registry build
some quick prototypes send commands to
the devices you can also receive data as
well so the other thing we have is we
have this is this is a dashboard which
we are built using cloud IOT core so we
have all these devices which are as I
mentioned deployed across Google offices
and this is collecting the data real
time so if I if I go to a specific
device I can just look at look at it
here and as you can see I'm getting
messages pretty much every second or
every two second any updates so it has
the temperature or humidity light and
pressure that data and and you can you
can collect all this data real-time you
can create some simple dashboard and you
can even have we are storing it in
bigquery so you can do some have
subsequent analysis based on this data
as well so to to just wrap it up we've
go back to the slides
perfect so we talked about three key
things one is on the cloud side with all
rightie core you can now securely
connect and manage your fleet of devices
so that you can collect data from your
devices and start using our data
analytics ingestion and storage and
machine learning capabilities on this
data and we also have Android things for
for edge device which you can get the
same level of security you can run some
local tensorflow to get insights at the
edge and you can also manage all these
devices at scale because Google takes
care of of the former update and former
version as well
now clarity call a work simulate with
the Android things work seamlessly with
clarity core but you can connect any
device it doesn't have to run Android
things you can connect any device with
raw which is running either Debian or
some other operating former operating a
former version as long as you skir n't
leave as long as you can connect you can
use mqtt to connect to clarity core and
start sending message so as the example
i gave you
is this small MCU which is not running
Android things but it runs a small horse
by Mongoose and Roger supports MQTT and
TLS and so it can connect a flower
article and start sending the messages
there as well so a couple of quick next
things is we have some helpful links so
for Android things you can go to
developer.android.com slash things for
IOT core it's cloud google.com slash IOT
- core Hydra core is in private beta so
you have to request access to start
using it and we review a review access
request and we looking at it and with
grant access based on your use case we
will in over the next couple of months
make it more broadly available so you
can start using it but if you really
want to if you want to use all encourage
you guys to go to the site and request
access so we can you can start using it
as well and there's a developer
community side as well that's it so
thanks and if you have questions do you
have time for questions we have some
time ok I can take one or two questions
in two minutes otherwise I'll be
standing outside if you have more
questions
do you also connect to other IOT
platforms would you the question is
would you connect to other IT platforms
so if the use case is that you have your
device's connecting to clarity core
because we publish our data to pop sub
you can have you can consume that data
and it can send it to other IOT platform
as well right so so you can you can set
it to your own inbuilt IOT solution or
you can send it to some other public
cloud provider but if your question is
around if I have my own IT solution IT
platform and how do I send the data you
could still use it using cloud to cloud
adapter so you can directly connect it
pops up or you can send it via via MQTT
to IOT core so it should be able to
support other platforms as well
okay thanks for coming and if you have
more questions I'll be signing outside
thank you
[Applause]